[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour un
nouveau 7,8 politique sur tv 78 dédié
aux élections municipales dans les
yvelines aujourd'hui focus sur sens hier
l'école avec la maire sortante sonia
bromont soir vous occuper ce poste de
maire depuis à peine un nom juste après
la démission de bernard demain vous est
partie de cette majorité
vous avez il avait porté à la liste à
laquelle vous appartenez en 2014
quel bilan vous fait aujourd'hui un an
après de cette écharpe tricolore que
vous arborez c'est passionnant qui a
beaucoup de travail et que saint cyr est
une très belle ville et que je suis
vraiment fier d'en être 100 m vous allez
mener pour la première fois une liste en
tant que tête de liste
à l'heure où de nombreux élus locaux
jettent l'épongé pourquoi avez vous fait
ce choix justement parce que j'ai encore
l'envié qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à faire à saint cyr et que je
pense que tant qu on a encore cette
envie vraiment de faire des choses pour
sa ville une fouille allez on va parler
de votre programme justement mais pour
vous présenter un petit peu plus vous
avez débuté en 2008 en politique à
saint-cyr-l'ecole en 2015 vous êtes
devenu aussi conseillère départementale
pour être bien clair si vous êtes élu
maire vous gardez ce mandat de maire
vous avez d'autres ambitions députés par
exemple aux autres non ce qui
m'intéresse vraiment c'est plus le
territoire c'est-à-dire au niveau local
le conseil départemental est vraiment le
premier partenaire de la commune et
c'est pour ça que c'est intéressant
d'aller au conseil départemental mais
mes ambitions elles sont localement
votre volonté dans cette campagne c'est
d'être dans la continuité de ce qui
s'est fait jusqu'à présent vous porter
aussi l'héritage de cette liste le bilan
de cette liste portée par bernard de
bain bien entendu alors si c'est très
compliqué parce qu'en fait c'est oui je
suis dans la continuité
oui je suis dans l'héritage et pourtant
on est dans une ville très dynamique qui
a beaucoup évolué sur ces douze
dernières années et qui a été en phase
de construction est aujourd'hui en fait
en 2001 nous étions quinze mille
habitants en 1975 on étaient 18000 on va
arriver à 20000 on a construit deux
quartiers et ses deux derniers mandats
ont servi en fait à construire les
équipements nécessaires pour accueillir
cette population et donc moi j'arrive à
un moment donné où finalement ce qu'il
reste à faire c'est mettre en oeuvre
tous ces équipements pour qu'ils servent
au saint cyrien et donc à vraiment
s'intéresser aux saints cyrille et que
tout cela fonctionne aussi aujourd'hui
il ya encore des choses à mettre en
route à équilibrer justement vous parlez
de ces nouveaux quartiers on pourrait
parler des transports aussi et qui a
toujours été plus ou moins un problème
sur saint cyr l'école st servile aussi
de passage entre saint quentin en
yvelines et versailles
finalement donc aujourd'hui l'accent est
aussi mis sur le développement des
transports par exemple sur sa vie des
reines évidemment et j'ai envie de dire
sur le développement des transports et
des transports propres
car aujourd'hui par exemple sur hydro
glisse on a envoyé la première molécule
hydraulique donc syndicat
d'assainissement qui traite les eaux
usées de notamment de saint cyr et dont
la station est à saint cyr et une partie
sur ben ali nous avons lancé la première
molécule de
de biogaz dans les réseaux de gaz de
ville le 4 décembre dernier
donc tout ça c'est pour préparer aussi à
une transition et des gaz pour des bus
en gas gas et non plus propre on revient
dans la constitution de la liste vos
équipes
il y aura une évolution sur la liste que
vous allez présenter il ya toujours une
évolution d'abord parce que la première
liste divers droite de saint pierre a
été élu en 2000 et que forcément les
personnes qui sont bons parce que l âge
aidant et plus envie de changer de faire
autre chose donc oui il ya un peu plus
de 50% de la liste qui sera niais qui
sera nouvelle donc ce sera une liste
pour être bien clair divers droite vous
vous êtes toujours eu des études et ils
vont rester vide est tout à fait
réaliste à des sensibilités diverses à
droite la liste des sensibilités
diverses à droite même si elle va de la
droite jusque des anciens ps ou des
personnes qui se revendique être en
marge on parle de l'évolution de cette
liste ceux concernant le programme vous
avez abordé la question notamment du
transport mais quelles sont les
priorités aussi que vous allez mettre en
avant les choses que vous allez mettre
en avant pendant cette campagne et les
priorités si vous êtes élue à la grosse
priorité je pense un pour le mandat à
venir c'est de redonner sa siros 1-1
sert de créer un centre ville de
privilégier les accès piétons
sachant quand même que saint cyr est
traversé par cinq départementale dont
trois importantes se regroupent sur la
place de la république est quand même en
centre de la ville mais prioriser
vraiment un centre ville des accès
piétons donné l'envi au saint siège de
se promener quitte à ce que ça
ralentissent le trafic et que ça donne
envie aux gens de passer par des chemins
extérieur se soit pas uniquement une
ville dortoir finalement puisque le
risque qu'on avec l'urbanisation ces
deux-là de devenir une ville sans âme
mais le but est de développer vous le
disais dans le centre ville on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir autre enjeu peut
être aussi la sécurité il ya eu des
sensibilités ça c'est comme partout mais
il ya aussi des tensions entre bandes
rivales parfois il y en a eu encore à la
fin de ce mois de janvier avec ait des
affrontements avec des des bandes
rivales de trappes notamment entre
trappe saint cyr l'école
quels sont les moyens dont vous pouvez
disposer pour ça
bien comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le département est vraiment le premier
partenaire de la ville et à ce sujet
nous avons monté dernièrement le fait
que la prévention les éducateurs de rue
ce qu'on appelait avant d'éducateurs de
rue soient à nouveau financées par le
département
même dans les quartiers qui ne sont pas
on peut en politique de la ville
c'est quelque chose qui va beaucoup
aider saint cyr car on voit bien la
différence entre le moment où nous
étions en quartiers politique de la
ville et ou bénéficiant de ce dispositif
est aujourd'hui d'encadrement
aujourd'hui manque de moyens pour
développer la police municipale les
équipements de vidéo protection et je
trouve comme ça alors aujourd'hui au
niveau au niveau du développement des
équipements municipaux chat tout ce qui
vidéoprotection
vous le savez c'est une compétence de
versailles grand parc et non pas de la
ville donc de l'agglomération laquelle
saint cyr l'école a tout à fait qu'on a
aujourd'hui quelque chose comme 25
caméras sur la ville on en promettait 30
en 2014
en revanche nous avons profité de ce
ralentissement
pour vraiment créer un centre de
surveillance intercommunale beaucoup
plus efficient parce que m 40 50 60
caméras
si vous n'avez pas de l'humain derrière
ça n'est pas probant donc on a fait ce
choix de mettre de l'humain plus que de
développer le nombre croissant de
caméras ce qui n'empêchera pas que ça va
continuer à évoluer
quant à la police municipale par exemple
quand je suis arrivé au mois de février
il y avait un policier municipal et deux
asvp
aujourd'hui j'ai trois policiers
municipaux et deux asvp
et si vous êtes élu vous allez renforcer
cette police municipale je pense que eu
égard là au nombre d'habitants sur saint
ciers il faut arriver à minima à 8
et si on veut commencer à travailler sur
une peau lisse avec des horaires élargis
il faudra passer à 12 après ça c'est le
rêve il ya les finances il ya
l'équilibré des budgets
ça s'appelle du fonctionnement c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui est compliqué et
j'ai envie de vous dire
surtout même 1,5 aujourd'hui on arrive à
avoir des nocturnes jusqu'à 20 heures
on arrive à avoir des samedis travaillés
ce qui permet de vraiment avoir une
police plus présente sur le terrain vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure la communauté
d'agglomération versailles grand parc
mont saint cyr l'école dépend ça restera
ainsi où vous avez une volonté de vous
rapprocher de saint quentin en yvelines
peut-être alors moi je ne vois que
l'intérêt de saint cyr l'école de
l'intérêt de saint cyr l'école
aujourd'hui et à versailles grand bar où
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est versailles
grand parc l'oci demain l'intérêt de
saint cyr était à saint quentin en
yvelines je pense qu'il faudrait se
poser la question mais la porte n'est
pas aujourd'hui fermée en fonction
d'intérêts de la commune une dernière
question aujourd'hui il y a deux listes
de déclarer sur cette commune de saint
cyr l'école en 2014 il y en avait cinq
est ce que vous craignez un manque
d'implication aussi des citoyens dans la
campagne dans la vie politique
la vie publique je crois que
nationalement on l'a vu il ya un vrai d
amour pour l'investissement dans la
politique locale
donc il ya dix-neuf mille habitants dans
une coque dans cette commune de saint
cyr l'école de tellement de liste ça
peut paraître peu surtout à saint cyr
l'école qui étaient habitués avant le
reste raymond 4 et 5 est un minimum
oui je j'ai envie surtout de dire aux
saint cyrien de pas se démobiliser et de
vraiment écouter chaque débat et d'aller
voir chez chacun pour vraiment faire
leur choix et de s'impliquer dans la
ville parce que ce soit au niveau
politique associatif
on a besoin de voir une ville dynamique
et je sais des saint cyriens ils seront
ils seront contents et 3 leur compte
mais pour la suite de votre campagne une
réunion publique est prévue le 27
janvier 27 février pendant et deux
autres suivront les 12 et 19 mars
tout à fait merci beaucoup sonia ben
rhodes est revenue tête de liste donc
sur cette campagne aux municipales 2020
sur saint cyr l'école maire sortante
merci à vous merci à vous
il devrait finalement y avoir deux
listes de gauche sur montigny le
bretonneux en mars prochain de listes
qui se sont rencontrés mais qui n'ont
pas trouvé de point d'accord l'une sera
porté par pierre déjean l'autre par
vivien gasquet cette dernière liste
vient de se réunir reportage marylène
yapi chine alternative unis montanes
écologie et solidaire dit m
et la troisième liste à se lancer pour
les élections municipales à montigny le
bretonneux à sa tête un binôme à l'image
des valeurs de collectifs de démocratie
participative qu'elle souhaite défendre
personnellement j'ai rejoint la liste m
montini par les valeurs de collectif cal
porte et le projet
de transition écologique où on arrive
aujourd'hui dans la société il faut
changer le monde
il faut enfin moi c'est mon envie c'est
de changer le monde et on peut commencer
à l'échelon local parce que c'est là
qu'on peut agir concrètement
pas d'étiquette politique ni aucun
soutien ne sera affiché la sensibilité
est tout de même à gauche et écologistes
règles électorales obligent viven gasc
sera numéro un du binôme et donc tête de
liste élue par les autres membres du
collectif on se présente un binôme tête
de liste et ça c'est important
et dans tout à notre action municipale
l'idée c'est de construire des binômes
avec des gens qui travaillent ensemble
et pas des décisions ultracentralisée
entre les mains d'une personne
transition écologique avec la notion
d'économie sociale et solidaire
démocratie participative avec l' envie
de dynamiser les conseils de quartier et
solidarité sont les trois grands piliers
du programme coup construit au cours
d'assemblées citoyennes une majorité des
gens qui sont sur cette liste des gens
de gauche pas tous et ça c'était
important pour nous l'ouverture c'était
la capacité à s'ouvrir
d'abord si on n'est pas capable entre
nous d'être un minimum ouvert on n'est
pas capable de convaincre une majorité
de nos montagnes notre ambition nous
c'est quand même de remporter l'élection
municipale
la liste m poursuit ses actions de
tractage dans la ville et de nombreuses
réunions publiques sont programmées par
quartier prochaine date le 31 janvier à
la maison de quartier henri matisse et
pour refermer ce numéro du 7-8 politique
deux dates c'est tout d'abord le
vendredi 31 janvier 19h othman natrue
lancera sa campagne aux côtés de
mustapha larbaoui les deux hommes alliés
pour ce scrutin présenteront les
principaux points de leur programme à la
salle jean baptiste clément et puis à
versailles le 6 février ce sera au tour
du maire sortant françois de mazières de
se lancer rendez vous à 20h à
l'université interâges pour ses soutiens
et ses administrés pour connaître ses
propositions économiques mais aussi en
matière de sécurité et d'urbanisme
c'est la fin du set 8 politique la
campagne des municipales est à suivre au
quotidien dans le journal des 18 heures
en direct et puis les replays ville par
ville sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile très belle soirée
[Musique]